so you're about to watch one of my best
title tuesdays ever
in this video i had my best ever upset
win in the title tuesday defeating a
really strong super grand master but i
also have a lot of really fun and
instructive games against some really
strong players i've time stamped
everything in the video description so
feel free top around at your leisure or
watch the whole thing through that's
usually encouraged before we get to the
chests i do want to thank the sponsor of
today's video which is audible if you
haven't heard of audible which you
probably should have by now they are a
massive platform of audiobooks and
spoken word entertainment
and there's so many different genres you
can find on audible between sci-fi and
fiction non-fiction
business the list goes on and on and
there's always something new to discover
on audible and let me give a sneak
preview into my audible library and just
share a few of the titles i've been
listening to recently
and one audiobook i want to highlight
one i've really been enjoying listening
to is called stolen focus why you can't
pay attention and how to think deeply
again by johann hari and this is an
audiobook that dives into just the
concept of focus
and how it's becoming increasingly more
difficult to stay focused in today's
world especially with all the
distractions of technology and social
media
and through listening to this book i've
realized how to employ different
strategies in which i can stay more
focused in my own life so i think this
is a really great kind of
self-improvement book
and one that i think will bring a lot of
value to those who uh who listen all the
way through so if you would like to try
out audible for free and get any audio
book of your choice including this one i
do have a special offer
for my viewers you can click the link in
the video description audible.com
i am rosen or text i am rosen to 500 500
i do hope it brings some value into your
life and thanks again to audible for
sponsoring today's video
now let's get to some chess
okay
i pre-moved queen d2
i don't know you could pre-move as white
before the first move
okay
london time
i do have to adjust because there is a
one second coming here
so no dirty flagging
queen b3 is idea
i don't mind the double pawns
yeah usually that i play this position
with the bishop on f5 bishop on g4 i
think i'll just win the tempo with h3
black might be considering this move
okay so black lost a tempo
i still play h3 to ensure that my bishop
has
room to move back
and now the plan is b4 b5
another plan is knight b3
2 a5
i think i can play b5 right away
because of this pin so the c pawn can
take but then i take with bishop
we might see rook c8 here
if rook's here they have to move the
bishop probably back to
[Music]
e2
and then the plan is b4 b5 yet again
another idea is to play c6
like if black plays e6 i think c6 wins
just immediately or no takes takes
i'll just be a trade
c6 takes c7
don't think it works
so the bishop um what does this move
opponent wants to play e5
i could play bishop e7
i think i'll just play b4
and then after e5 just bishop g3
i want to castle probably play rook c1
and then still go for this plan
because b7 is a bit weak
if i can attack the pawn and the rook
has to go here then it's aligned with
the bishop
okay
maybe should have considered knight f3
but
and this is a plan now
b6
okay
thinking f3
if i take
there's also rook
rook d8 or d1
some idea to take and then win d5
with f4 here
f4 takes f5
it looks weird it's a bit
anti-positional
but the idea is to open the diagonal
so the point is if it takes i play f5
hitting this and this
and if takes takes i hit the rook rook
moves i win the pawn
and then d6 is weak
okay
probably throw in the check
okay here i win the rook
and now i'll probably take the pawn
my fan is blowing a little bit too much
okay
i mean i probably have to take
another pawn
i think just h4
i'm leaving b4 hanging but if black
takes it and bishop f4 check
logical
i'm allowing rook c3 but knight d4 hits
the thing and i'm also hitting a6
and then there's massive x-ray vision
i mean it's just a big shish kebab on
the six rank
so if takes takes takes my windmill
or rook g6
okay nice game
got the job done there
okay
playing lid
okay another london
should be five's a trendy line these
days
queen b3 is also a line queen b3 bishop
d6
this is a gambit line
um
[Music]
white's not interested in taking the
gambit
i think i'm supposed to defend the pawn
i'm just forgetting my prep
or rook b8
why am i not remembering
probably just rook b8
and castling
expecting bishop b2
should play h3 pretty soon or h6
a6 first
there's some rooks right fc8
that's some 95 idea
and then go for minority attack
okay change the plans
taking bishop d2 doesn't work
a very positional game
not sure what my plan is
maybe eventually b5
maybe some rook b6
queen c7
so if b5 takes takes
and
i just can't really allow b4
put the bishop back
and maybe my queen should be on d6 here
um
the idea is to discourage queen a3
i mean why plays it anyway
um
i could take and play
a5
okay i should bring the king to d6
oh wait my rook's stuck though
what's my rook doing
king c7 rook d6
um
g5 may be coming
but maybe not
okay
i think i want to play like h5h4
if i get the chance
my rook should be elsewhere
how do i trade bishops
wow
such a weird plan
[Music]
i just want to play h5
why rook's doing
if f5 i have e5
i should probably play f6 and then go
for h5
[Music]
c4 i play d4
although i'm not sure
[Music]
king g3 is a bit strange
up on time finally
active rook
attack from behind
hmm
i think this is okay
should be very okay
i could try
okay
oh man that's like work
a lot of these these sort of end games
they come down to patience and just
keeping composure
a lot of like kind of moving around
aimlessly from both of us
but then when things kind of opened up
and it got spicy i was calculating this
line um bishop c6 rook d4
i'm not sure what's going on there
because i'm a bit pinned
but then if we go into the kingpin
ending
white ends up being in zuzwan i think
okay so two other two
tied with akaru
am i at my peak blitz rating
hey peak blitz rating
27.41
i shouldn't worry too much about rating
but
that's a nice achievement
yeah they're just playing out rook
wait what
what's happening
it's not showing moves it's just showing
the clock moving back and forth
that's so weird
i've never seen this before
do we cover a new bug or do we uncover a
new bug
oh they're passing
yeah this is a new rule that's been
added to chess you can pass
instead of making a move
that's so strange
there's stock on move 103.
oh they went from 103 to 122.
king vs king
oh i'm playing boardnik okay bortnik
likes to play the job of london
i don't know what to play against jilba
london
i mean knight c3 is coming
play this line
um yeah let's take
like queen d2
i think i've seen queen d2 before
take knight c6
now this is new territory for me
probably bishop f5 here
[Music]
get ready for this and this
so e5
we trade i take on c5
and then the e3 square is nice for me
so bishop e3
probably i take an f6
interesting
yeah that's a better version
[Music]
i could take on e4
okay that move i forgot about
i have rook d4 here
there's also a5 maybe start with a5
a5 and then rook d4
if b5 rook t4 is interesting
oh wait b5 i can take
um okay let's take
a3 is still coming so probably b6 at the
right moment
for this
b6 is bishop b5
i think it's okay bishop knight a7 is
basically c7
okay i forgot why i could do it but
we're
we're pretending this was all part of
the plan
i think i should play g4
[Music]
that comes to c4
[Music]
that's annoying
interesting line where i get rook f2
the problem is white's threatening b5
i have to play some ugly move
king d8
and b5 still comes man
i mean i'm losing i think
of king
to play like some knight b8
that's really ugly
or that
there's even like i couldn't take on g2
because bishop e4
that's so sad
[Music]
oops there goes my rook
okay i gotta play that game it was a
weird opening
i took a lot of time trying to like
figure out
the
the intricacies of the position
um definitely a game to learn from
though
queen d2 is a new move for me the main
line as far as i know
is c3 takes here
[Music]
uh knight c6
i think knight c6 and then takes and
then bishop f5
i mean it seemed like i got it
there's a lot of bugs today the the
notation is not showing what move
it still says we're on c3
okay
uh
i should have done this earlier
yeah so this is becoming a more popular
line this um this e4
pawn sacrifice
oh bortnik has had
bourtnick played this back in 2016.
so we played queen d2
i'm really surprised there's not more
games in the masters database
but maybe it's such a new line that um
there's been more recent games
so first of all queen d2
is playable okay
so i took
knight c6 is fine
so engine really likes e5 i didn't play
e5 because this and then
i'm pinned but apparently
wow
also thank you vmgz
gifting five i appreciate that
this is actually really nice so even
though i can't take the bishop right
away
i can take the bishop eventually
with this move hitting this preparing
this
and this unpins the e pawn and hits a
king and the next move i'll take the
bishop
so
if i saw that maybe i would play e5
and then apparently black's already much
better because bishop e3 f5
and f4 is already a threat
that's a funny line g3 g5
bishop g5 bishop c5 wow
okay that's a nice lesson
wait so what happened the game i played
bishop five immediately
and
okay it was close to equal
[Music]
engine stars like much better after ef3
ah because it takes i have f2
[Music]
yeah i played f6 kind of reflexively
and if knight takes
then f6
bishop e3
knight before wow
it's crazy it's like already minus five
even though it's equal material
i don't know if i fully understand this
like for
rookie two knight a2 king b1
we're threatening mate
how's this minus six almost
rook d5 i guess white's just a bit stuck
strawfish is so savage
okay good lesson to take away
playing carton
or carton i should say
dutch okay i'll play um play some london
e6
a stonewall interesting
yeah i don't mind the trade
queen e2
some cases like castle queenside
h3 some idea g4
if c5 i probably just play c3
um
f3 queen h4
hey maybe g4 here
a little bit risky
let's move to
and be patient i want to keep a piece on
the e5 square i don't want my pawn to
have to trade
because e5 square is just a gaping hole
[Music]
and the difference between these knights
is i have long term potential for f3 and
black can never play f6
wow so if i play c3 there's knight c3
can i trap the bishop in the end
king f1 queen c2
not sure
walk the king to c2 there
i should probably just play king f1
a difficult position to understand here
rook
rook t1
i mean what is this clump of pieces
what is this
i think bishop b1 is logical
maybe my king can walk to h2
even knight h2
then i'll lost g5
maybe each four then
wait
some bishop b5 ideas
if i take
maybe i should just get the bishop here
my thought process was kind of scattered
i think this is logical
[Music]
so if i take on e4
maybe h4
gone about a minute
i mean g3 king g2 is some weird idea
okay i can always take on e4 if i get
too scared
now next move i do want to play f3 and
drop the knight
so knight g4 i think i just went upon
aha
let's see what happens here
takes
so f3 knight f2
not sure though
rook h2
[Music]
i have to keep h4 defended
the calculation is after it takes takes
the knight's trapped
still tricky position to play though
i think the other knight should move to
f2 because in h2 would have been covered
and worked you want to lost h4
okay
probably g3 rook f2
bishop's terrible there
okay finds a new home on g4
d4 always runs into queen e4
feel the peace
do you want to take on d5 play rt224
okay
it's not easy to win games man
let's go
okay three out of four
a new all-time high rating
yeah i mean i took a lot of time
because i think it was worth it around
here to try and figure out the
calculation
but i i wasn't sure what i was gonna do
after this
like this could be a lot more
troublesome
looks like it shouldn't make a
difference but uh
you have knight h2 oh maybe maybe rook
h2 still
this doesn't look right though
takes with check takes takes
but maybe this would be an option for me
bishop g3
do you have a london opening class yeah
we have the london command
in which uh
yeah it's an eight-hour video course i
made on london
um
this is a pretty rare line
because it weakens e5 so it's not
appealing for
for most players
and white's supposed to just be slightly
better here
i'm curious if i uh
if i had any other like better chances
okay so king f1 yeah i was spending some
time looking at c3 i probably spent too
much time here
i was calculating these lines where i
have queen c2 king e2 but i think it's
too slow
because like queen b4 and the queen or
bishop
will move to c3
g4
yeah already like box doing fine
it's very hard position to judge what's
going on though
wait so this is fine for me so what
happens after knight ef2
oh i just take the knight and trap the
knight in the corner
yeah so many potential night traps
oh i took the wrong night
oh wow both knights are trapped
i didn't even realize that i can take
here
and this knight is trapped
i took there
yeah i pre-moved queen b2 but my
opponent took on e3
apparently black is a little bit for
choice
but
yeah having the two bishops is still
nice for white okay i missed c4
if i saw c4 i'd probably play it
and eventually my opponent dropped e6
i didn't have enough time to calculate
this i mean maybe i could have just
played it intuitively
i guess the point is e6 is gonna fall in
this line
um
okay
okay oh i'm playing duboff
have i played dubai before
we may have played a few times on
leachat actually
this might be our first time playing on
chess.com
did i take this picture i may have taken
this picture of him
let's take a few photos of him at world
cup
g6 okay let's play this line
so c5 takes queen a5 there's one trap
thing
if queen a5 queen d2 never mind
oh yeah i know this line
i usually take and play bishop e5 but
it's not a good move
i think bishop bishop b5 the way to go
i measure b5 it's been a while since
i've looked at this
i'm hitting the knight
twice okay i have f3 here
d5 isn't quite hanging or is it
i don't think d5 is hanging
and take and get the bishop hair
i'm temporarily up upon
i think i just castle kingside soon
i wonder if bishop e5 is playable like
queen d7 bishop e5
wait what
and win this pawn
issue is queen a5
and queen e5 looks risky for black too
and he might play it but
wow so knight's hanging
i kind of want to play a4 here takes
takes king c king of two
i could take on c3 as well
[Music]
um i don't see how he's winning back the
piece after it ticks takes takes king f2
oh there's not a six
queen d2 doesn't work i'm gonna have to
go for this there's king d1 but
and i have six is coming
do bob so tricky
i have queen d4
queen e5 here
it was very mature
[Music]
that's interesting actually
winnie seven it's very materialistic
the point is queen g5 after knight d5
and it takes i have e4
i'm still up a pawn
like king is randomly on g3
but dark squares are kind of weak
oh g6 is defended i have queen h6
thankfully
i don't want to
get my queen dropped
all right e4 hitting the knight and ooh
oh he's running this and this
wow
i have roxy one
playrook c1
kh2
the problem is there's a mate thread on
g2
maybe i can keep bobbering like the
queen
which it takes i have queen c2 in the
end there
so here here it takes in queen c2
i think saves me
so a little bit low on time
for g7 probably e4
i got the chance
he's so sneaky
okay so we have four ideas
e4 is still on the horizon
d1 rook a1
g6 is still tender
oh there's a really cool line
all right i stack on e7 and take on g6
oh there's queen e6 though
[Music]
uh let's start with this anyway
playing for a win
let's bishop f8
let's go
let's go i missed bishop f8 the first
time
but found it the second time
nice game
also i think i've hit a peak heart rate
like ever on stream
let's go
also new peak blitz rating
275.
okay
yep
overall i think that was a
i mean
it was i think a nice game
there were some like small things i
missed initially but
uh
i was seeing tactics quicker than usual
thanks everyone i appreciate the hype
okay this is definitely my best ever
start
to a title tuesday
there was a title tuesday a few weeks
ago i beat makzulu
um
i don't think i was four out of five
my name is still not visible or is it
where am i
hey i'm visible i'm tied for 26.
i'm the very last in the standings here
okay playing another gm no time not so
much time to cool down
who's this
oh i'm playing alex senko
okay
i'll play accelerated dragon
[Music]
andrea botez was sharing
this opening on her stream yesterday
to remember lessons from that stream
i also have to remember my prep
and i played this in iceland
so it takes in bishop d6
like c2 is a move
wait i showed this in a
[Music]
oh no i didn't show this in youtube
video yet but the line is to take in the
bishop h6 i think
and then e5
i play the 1800 elo and iceland who also
played rook c1 let's go and i checked
analysis after the game and this is
this is the engine's recommendation
although it gets weird after this takes
takes
i think bishop c6 in the end
um f4
e5 still probably makes sense
and it's the whole idea
now i'm playing this kind of blindly but
okay relying more on intuition
and remembering
okay so now i could take the rook
i have nothing reasonable to say but
i'll still type this one out for no real
reason we all love you eric less than
three oh thank you i'm also muting
alerts because i wanna try and stay
focused here
um
[Music]
i take some nike
for the problem is i might be getting
mated really quickly
oh maybe it's okay
and the problem is 95 comes too
[Music]
before it takes
this might already be really bad for me
i don't have any other move
queen b6
g4 takes takes
i mean i'm up to exchange but the
position is just crumbling
95.
maybe i can give it back
but then i'm down two pawns
and it takes a knight d5 f6 takes takes
bishop takes queen v6 king h1
i promise queen h6 is coming in these
lines
okay that move i'm
that move might also just win
[Music]
like how do i stop
how do i not get mated here
man
oh i have an idea
there's an f5
problem is knight d5 ah
nothing works
i want to play this but then knight
my d5 is coming
hmm
i mean what else to do
at least i'll have some time to recover
because this is probably going to end
really soon
though the hope is to get queen versus
rook and then set up some stalemate drop
uh that's not even happening
i couldn't take because uh
i would lose
i'm just gonna resign
okay that was a rough game
i tried playing this uh it's interesting
opening idea
let's analyze
it's a valuable lesson though
uh
okay
yeah no time to bring in the do off game
after bringing that game later
yeah if it was just joining i i beat
duval and then just had this game
against alexenko
oh this has been played before though
okay so
yeah i was remembering some rook c2 and
then e5
but f4 most played
and then
that e5 is just a blender okay
yeah i should have probably
been a little bit more careful
this is a danger of like
remembering a single movement opening
preparation but not understanding
the resulting lines
i just assumed e5 was the idea but
i guess in this case idea white can't
play f3
and
um
yeah now the pawn is attacked
and the bishop f3 i take on f4
so it's a little bit awkward for white
to defend the pawn
i guess black doesn't mind this trade
knight d5
ah take some queen b6 nice resource
okay next time i'll know
if f4 bishop c6
but if this move then we play e5
bishop e3
and then i was trying to remember this
so this is and this are playable
i'm not sure if i like understand why 98
immediately
i guess it does defend the pawn
i mean 90 oh 98 queen g5 ideas
that's kind of cool queen g5 these pawns
are weak bishop e6 coming
okay and then real quick let me just see
the end of this game
i think i was just dead though
yeah 98's the best try but
bishop six good move
okay
a valuable lesson
sometimes valuable lessons can also be a
little bit painful
okay so i'm playing low-rate player
again
earthquake
from poland
i'm just gonna play a london
um i actually know some theory here
if if e6 knight f6 is played
like e6 and then yeah
i prepared this a while ago for spidler
of course fiddler i wasn't expecting him
to play a6 on move one
but he plays a line with like knives b5
against london
and the idea is after d5 i play queen b3
i think it's still queen b3
queen c8 rook c1
there's rook a7 too
or k7 might be played
and i think rook c1
yeah so some pressure here
oh 95 is a threat
probably queen a4
yeah the goal is probably just a castle
i might throw an h6
h5 might be consideration for black or
h3 i should say
i'm doing well on the clock
and bishop e2
and also a3
a3
a3 is okay
if takes i take back i think
i don't mind the double pawns
okay i could take
i'll just keep things simple
[Music]
oh 94 coming i have to take with pawn
then
um
forgot about
94. forgot about that move too man
i'm bishop
oh no
not have a good response
i'm already in trouble
maybe it's okay
like some rook b3 idea
knight e4 rook b3
ah i miss bishop a4
wait this is what i wanted though
wait no that's not what i wanted
ah everything's crumbling
um
okay let's fight
there's missing so many things this game
the black doesn't see this move
apparently okay they saw it
the good thing is there's obstacle
bishops
and i'm turning this i'm also
threatening this this
which isn't really a threat but
maybe it's something some g4 ideas
if f5
i take on e6 no i can't the a6 is
defended
i think i'll just castle
[Music]
knight e5 knight g4
okay interesting
i mean let's start with c4 and then d5
hmm
so f7 is a target d7 could be a target
this is a nice juicy square
definitely some hope here
i like to play queen e3
e5 is a good move
hmm
looks really wrong with king g2 or kh2
and then queen d2
i have to prevent f5 though
black finds it
there's still some idea queen d2 queen
g5
here up ticks
i gotta go all out
25
this doesn't work at all but
have some hope
not good
yeah well played oh what to do
oh i tried to be tricky
almost got enough counter play
oh i can't even i can't even like click
on the notation
oh i can use arrows
um
yeah another loss is another lesson
so i just wondered a3 this game
yeah there's a cool line like if
if
if d5 here then queen b3
improving on caruana's game
and then if rook a7 there's bishop b5
there's some crazy
ideas where we keep sagging the bishop
yeah i didn't sense the danger here i
should take um
bishop g3 i think i played really
quickly too
which just allowed
initiative for black
if i take then light takes and then this
is completely different
and then it's just very stable it's
still a fight maybe f5 castling
but then the queen side is held together
hey thank you lele
appreciate the rain i wonder if lele was
playing at least part of title tuesday
if you're just joining we are midway
through
title tuesday
just finished round seven i wanna say
more than halfway through
yeah the reason why i'm analyzing on
leachates is because
first of all i can save all my games so
if i like if i want to go back to any
it's like it's much easier it's just one
click away
and all my analysis would be saved too
and
in previous streams i was having issues
like when i turned on the
engine on chess.com it was
it was lagging a little bit
um there's also built-in opening book
here so there's just a few features i
prefer
okay playing bug crusher
play this
um
let's see three
maybe a6
i should really know what i'm doing here
takes an na6
there's b6
and c5 might happen
i don't think c5 is as bad when the
bishops like on c1
i do waste time moving the
thing
huh
okay so
expecting a3
because white wants to play a3 b4
unless i don't want to play a3 b4
now i have b6
it doesn't look pretty though
knight fd7
i look so passive
i'm also just moving to slowly so f4 the
idea is f6
there's a line like f4 f6 knife three
so now i can take
question if i want to play g6
i can also play knight t7
i'll play knight d7 first
g6 looked a little bit too risky
okay weird opening so far
really
this idea of this
maybe f6 if
the timing is right
wait because half expecting f4 there
i know that f4 bishop basics
okay
what to do
i think f5
maybe f6 actually
i have two bishops might as well try and
open the position
d4
d4 is really just an attempt to simplify
because i'm getting low on time
i just want an easier position to play
if knight moves i take the pawn if queen
takes we trade queens and
i take on e5 and bishop t5 both moves
come with initiative
that move i didn't see
take take
i have to take
some queen h3 check but e5 is going to
come
wow
takes
there's a really funny line
[Music]
have a good one i'm talking a queen
thanks
i saw queen h3 but
i'm trying to make sense of this
because rookie one i see no no i'm
threatening rook d1
g3 or f3 both look kind of ugly
um because i'm gonna have like c2
there's a lot of initiative here
bishop might develop but let's see two
rook t1
just very little time
there's about four
bishop a6 takes takes
i think this is a safer option
maybe not best but
keeps things alive
yeah queen b3 very strong move
i think i have to go into the saki 6.
no really
uh
wondered a little bit
still tricky though
i'm winning a queen
now i'm safe
definitely playing for a win
let's go
did i miss something i feel like a lot
of things were probably missed
in the time scramble
man
yeah thankfully i was not the bug being
crushed that game
it was very hard to judge the queen
at first it looks like a queen blunder
this is such an easy move to miss
nice but
i
um
it's really hard to calculate this fully
i think white played some really good
moves
like bishop f4 should be best in rook f1
and i don't have time for rook d1
because the bishop still covers the
square
and then this was really strong
not only hitting c2 but
ensuring that when i play this this is
hanging
but white didn't take the e6 pawn
and then we got the two rooks for the
queen and this is still super tricky
for a moment it looked like white was
going to be promoting
okay
gg
uh five points
that was round eight no was it
thanks once again eric for the awesome
content
love from belgium oh thank you rob
inspector
okay so that was round eight so we have
another
break okay do i know this person
polish grandmaster
yeah move order can be interesting here
if e6 i play e3 if this i would play
knight c3
so bishop b4 knight fd2 is uh the main
line
i'm preserving knight c3 for later
bishop b7 most expected
[Music]
there's a line bishop b7 knight c3 c5 d5
which i had in a otb game once
d5
i had this in a recent title tuesday
actually
and i got a really bad position
i think i was playing aramacopian
okay this should be pleasant
i'm threatening this fork hitting c7 and
h7 c5 is expected
[Music]
i have known f3
castling maybe castling
because the queen might want to develop
before the knight comes in
all right c6 probably rook c1
probably still
[Music]
how to do this
and queen f3
so now i'm preventing c4 because the
pawn is pinned to the bishop
some ideas queen h3
or queen g3
rook c1 is typically a useful move
so now it's defended maybe bishop e5
here
preparing bishop f5 there's queen g4
trying to force a queen trade
i think queen g4 i can take on f6
takes takes and forces double pawns
otherwise i win c5
um
okay now there's about five
queen eight expected
wow forgot about queen b5 but
okay so what's happening b2 is hanging
[Music]
queen h3
and there's g6
play b3
oh i can take on c5 in those lines
maybe taken c5 right away
[Music]
there's rook d1 just positional chess
interesting
oh i miss bishop g4
not good
no simple tactics i should have just
traded played simple
of chicks i could take and
i hit the queen
opponent forgot the queen was hanging
okay
oh
yeah this move was disguised as like a a
simple
simple trade
sometimes it's hard to see that bishops
can move backwards
yeah i had this idea earlier where like
the
there were cases where the bishop wasn't
defended with my queen's phone f3
but i guess it works out
okay i'm fortunate to win that one
we both missed simple tactics
i miss a simple skewer but black missile
simple
uh bishop takes queen
yeah there's different levels of
complexity of tactics and chess
but like the simplest chess tactic is
taking a free piece
oh i'm playing msb2
i think i played on leachates a bit
we've played in the past
okay london time
ah this line
bishop d3 makes some sense
there's some problem with
uh a4 is also a move
a4 first
even a5 here
bishop
bishop d3
yeah b6 is a good move
until you can play knight d2
[Music]
opponent has barely lost any time
so somebody rook a4 rook a1 and just
target the a pawn
okay if we trade
queen g3 even queen f3
actually trading everything i think is
safest
i'm not better here but i don't think
i'm too much worse
should bring my king to d3
yeah i'm probably just playing for a
draw here
i think this is okay
is going to have to move back at some
point
if e5 takes bishop g3
probably f3
c4 i think is timely
for
like before king c3
h4 i think i played visual h2
keep control over the f4
square the idea is after it takes takes
i want to play d5
i kept liking c4
i think it's 97
[Music]
i'll probably this first
bishop d6 ideas now
i'll walk the king up
um
kind of nervous here just because it
still takes work to defend
it's very close to a draw though
h4 i have f4
[Music]
5.
moving way too slowly
uh
wait for oh no
uh
uh
there is almost a stalemate trick
actually
if um
[Music]
if you're here at mensac i would play
here and then hope for the pre-move
oh that's unfortunate
i mean i had this it was slightly
slightly
more comfortable for black because this
h3 pawn
and somehow
i just got way too long time king d3 but
the king was ready to walk around
and this pawn was always defended
what to do
so there's something called the 50 move
rule
which is an actual rule in chess
that if 50 moves go by with no captures
or pawn moves
then
the game is a draw
but because black has two pawns what it
looks like he's doing
is like
when it's like move 49 or when it's
close to 50 move rule he'll push upon
and then the 50 move counter resets so
this game could go on for another
uh probably 250 moves so we might get to
move 500
or wait no there's potential captures
too
uh
wait so one two three four
that's 200
yeah i could go on for another 300 moves
because of two captures
so we we might get to move like
550 something
and then we can do the math so 300 moves
is equivalent to
600 seconds because one second garment
for both players
which is equivalent to 10 minutes
so we could be here for a little bit
longer
a resignation
i imagine that was chess.com stepping in
to like force resign
um it would be funnier if
they made the other player resign the
one random player
oh i'm playing a harlem brewington
i think that's his name something
brewington
young talent in us i know he's done
content for chess kid
final game
we have a
accelerated dragon
and bishop c4 is the main line
yeah with bishop e2 i think
uh was it
trying to remember i think it's d5 takes
knight p4
maybe this is also a line
so if i play knight d7
i kind of just want to play e6 and then
c5
there's potential for light to attack
but
also potential for black to is control
some nice space
threatening a fork
uh bishop a6
there's a4
a4 rook b8 queen e2 queen b6
d4
i think i'll start with
let's start with this move
and some rook d8
could be it
that's kind of a weird standstill here
rook d8 may be coming next
i'm not sure which what either of us
want to do
queen is queen c6 runs into 97
[Music]
d4
i don't want to take too soon on b5
either
i play bishop b7 knight d6 bishop eight
eventual bishop f3
maybe i'll go for this though
making way for a6
or even d4 now
f2 expected
okay so now i have some like discovery
tricks
maybe c4 to start
um
[Music]
oh it's taking too long here
so basically for d3
king h1 we trade
this one eventually knight c5
okay i like to see that move
i have to make this work
there's tactics with a6 and uh knight d6
and then
knight takes e5 in the end
i also take right away
i think this is okay though
so 96 95
yeah i think this is why the king should
have moved to h1
so if ticks i take with the check and
then bringing the knight
and the rook's still hanging
i could even consider rook d5 here
i mean
no need to be fancy though
i don't think i want to take the rook
actually
those bishops too strong
or too valuable i actually keep it on
the board
okay now rook d5
i do rook h5 g4 might happen
then i probably invade vsc2
if rook c1 rook c2 still
because after the trade i hit uh the
bishop
i'm currently up
up one pawn
but say for a king
centralized queen
maybe it wasn't necessary
ah
oh no my pawn
i do have rook h8 now
still tricky
can we have three bishop h4
it's setting up bishop h4
missing bishop
c3
okay one more time
i think white had chances towards the
very end there to play bishop's e3
um
i i felt like i was in good control the
whole game but uh
actually maybe not the whole game like
the hero is tricky
but once i played c4 uh that was a
momentum
shift okay
that concludes title tuesday
7 out of 11.
a better score than i usually get on
stream
uh the highlight was definitely beating
duboff
had a crazy game against juvov earlier
also peak heart rate also peak rating
peak rating was 27 55.